هذا مشاهدينا نبدا نشاتها بخبر تحطم
الطائره النيباليه و يتابع معا هذه الصور
التي وصلتنا للتو ويعتقد انها للحظه سقوط
الطائره رئيس وزراء نيفا المشاهدين دعا في
هذا السياق لاجتماع طارق للحكومه بعد
كارثه تحطم طائره الركاب واعلن ايضا
المتحدث باسم يا شيفال عن وفاه 16 مسافر
على الاقل يتحطم طائره شركته فيما اكدت
شركه الطيران ان 10 اجانب من بين ركاب
الطائره المكومه المتحدث المشاهدين باسمي
هذه الشركه شركه ايضا في وقت السابق ان
طائره علمتها اثنان وسبعون شخصا تحطمت في
نيبال صباح اليوم الاحد كما اضاف للمتحدث
ايضا
فان الطائره كان علمتناها 86 راكبا واربعه
من افراد الطاقه واكد متحدث ايضا ان عمليه
الانقاذ هي ولا يعرف ما اذا كان هناك
ناجون حتى الان